the prime minister said
he felt no shame over the by-election
defeats he said his government have been
quite exceptional well i agree that
they've been exceptional all right an
exceptional record on stagnant wages
rising poverty
and broken promises and the prime
minister wants to drag this out until
2030s and how much more can he stomach
before he finds the guts mr speaker how
many more tax risers how many more
families drove into poverty and how many
manifesto pledges broken i hope for the
sake of the british public mr speaker
that we never find out and when will the
deputy prime minister finally grow a
backbone and tell the prime minister the
game is up
[Applause]
mr speaker i can't help thinking that my
honourable lady is auditioning for the
leadership contest on that side not
really referring to anything on this
side
[Applause]
well
she's
well she's she's got the support of the
honourable member
i'll tell you what we're doing we're
putting in place the policies to grow
our economy to help that
mr murray
we've had a good
questions already for scotland it's not
continued it's not your debate come on
mr speaker he was just announcing his
support for the right honourable lady in
the forthcoming
we're putting in places the economic
plan to help people with the cost of
living at the labor leader is getting
ready for year zero we are the ones
supporting ukraine with sanctions on
russia with military support the
honourable lady voted to abolish trident
we're the ones making the streets safer
more police and tougher sentencing under
the police crime sensing act in force
this week she voted against both they
got no plan they're not fit together mr
speaker
[Applause]